this weekend the 42nd annual Kennedy
Center Honors celebrated music legends
Earth Wind & Fire the Jonas Brothers
perform one of the Bands many hit songs
boogie wonderland during that tribute
that will air this Sunday on CBS CBS
this morning Saturday co-host Michelle
Miller caught up with the 1970s
supergroup on tour good morning Earth
Wind & Fire got its name from the
elements in the astrological chart of
the band's founder Maurice White and
though he died three years ago after
complications from Parkinson's disease
the surviving members of the band are
still inspiring audiences around the
world we met them at Northern
California's mountain winery where they
continued to spread White's music and
more importantly his spiritual message
of unity to generations of fans
after nearly 50 years Earth Wind & Fire
still rehearses before every show don't
you know the words that's what everybody
says but you can never not work on your
craft you're always working on it every
day you know particularly the level we
want to stay at and work in unison
if rehearsal starts at 8:00 in the
morning on this seven if it starts at
random there at 9:00 everybody he'll be
the first never met a stage he didn't
like yeah that's true you could say
Verdine white grew up on stage he was 19
when his half brother Maurice white
founded the group in 1970 all of a
sudden he says I'm bring you to
California and off you went off I went
Earth Wind & Fire would help define the
soundtrack of early blaxploitation film
but when their first two albums for
Warner records failed to move up the
charts the original lineup disbanded
leaving just Maurice and Verdean I
wasn't leaving my brother I love my
right I wasn't you know I wasn't
sticking out of what's going on I had
auditioned as a drummer in truth the
brothers first drafted drummer Ralph
Johnson then singer Philip Bailey we
went to for the tax reason I did it was
on a Sunday night - do you remember that
detail mm-hmm and you said where we
talked to him and he said I just want to
be in the best band in the world how'd
that turn out
[Laughter]
[Music]
Maurice White approached the band's
second act as a mission to broaden its
appeal and better focus its message he
wanted to deliver a message of hope and
love and respect and raise the
consciousness of the people so each one
of us was hand-picked you know for this
mission would you call it a spiritual
journey most definitely
and all of you are on board with it that
goes to another point you know there was
no drugs or alcohol as part of your
mission I mean is your scene
you lived clean when it came to your
food some of their some of them came
with we can't tell that lie there were
people in the group who got high okay
and and we got sweets pregnant you know
no we did
[Music]
at what point did you start noticing the
crossover taking place you know you
can't really put your finger on it but
you know a hit don't hurt you tiny star
pretty much just broke the door open
shining star first top Billboard Hot 100
in 1975 and the hits kept coming it was
just an electrical time where there was
nothing that we could do that was wrong
it was just horrible he was hitting on
all cylinders
[Music]
though it would be years before he
acknowledged his illness
maurices diagnosis of Parkinson's
disease forced him from touring in 1994
he died in 2016 we had to make a
decision could we go on without Maurice
would the audience's accept us without
Maurice so the three of us took it
forward mind you don't forget now that
hole he had was huge so we had to like
really put it together which we did
[Music]
Verdine white philipbaillie Ralph
Johnson continued their mission to bring
music to the masses and now this when
you see this
and they've seen that mission
accomplished
Wow more than 12 million people have
watched this video on YouTube featuring
Earth Wind and Fire fans of all ages and
backgrounds so what does that say to you
that music is a powerful tool we are
very blessed to be a part of something
that was and is so well received around
the world the rainbow ribbon signifies
cultural impact more than just music
yeah it's more than just music
you've changed music and enriched the
lives of generations to come
kind of gets back around to maurices
intense running day one yep to render
service to humanity and I'll be there it
is Reese a lot you know I'm thinking
about him now he left it in our hands
and he was proud of it and he was proud
of what we accomplished so I'll be
thinking about him yeah if you ever get
a chance to go see them in person I
highly highly highly recommend still
amazed how much amber yep the best the
back and watch the Kennedy Center Honors
this Sunday at 8:00 7:00 central here on
CBS we will be right back
[Music]